also die politische atmosphäre die
atmosphäre zwischen politik und den
medien in österreich sowieso schon
aufgepeitscht und jetzt noch diese ibiza
videos das ganze wirft grundsätzliche
fragen auf über die man sprechen kann
mit dem datenschutzbeauftragten von
baden württemberg mit stefan brink den
ich recht herzlich in stuttgart begrüßt
begrüße ich grüße sie herr bringt wir
haben sie deshalb eingeladen weil ihre
stellung stellungnahme uns bei phoenix
aufgefallen ist wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe dann sagen sie
der zweck heilige nicht die mittel meint
sie damit man hätte das ebita video gar
nicht veröffentlichen dürfen ja darauf
läuft es am ende hinaus es ist
vollkommen klar dass die presse selbst
entscheidet welche themen von
öffentlicher relevant sind und wie und
wie ausführlich sich sie darüber
berichtet aber im vorliegenden fall habe
ich zu kritisieren dass über ein
wortbeitrag hinausgegangen wurde und das
video das offensichtlich aus kriminellen
umständen herrührt zeitgleich ins netz
gestellt wurde
das ist aus meiner sicht gravierende
verletzung auch von
datenschutzrechtlichen aspekten aber man
muss doch die unterschiedlichen
rechtsgüter abwägen es muss ja
tatsächlich immer abgewogen werden was
liegt denn wiegt schwerer in diesem fall
ist es nicht so dass die erkenntnis dass
fdp politiker offenbar leicht verführbar
sind höher wiegt als der schutz der
privatsphäre
da stimme ich vollkommen mit ihnen
überein es geht nicht um die frage ob
presse über sowas berichten darf das ist
unbestritten und übrigens auch von
staatlichen stellen auch von
datenschützern nicht zu kontrollieren
das geht uns nichts an
es geht hier konkret um die frage ob es
zulässig war das video zeitgleich ins
netz zu stellen
durch das video werden die betroffenen
zusätzlich und sozusagen wiederholt in
ihren rechten verletzt
das video stammt nach allem was wir
wissen aus kriminellen machenschaften
und wenn ich das vorführen und ins netz
stelle und allgemein verbreite dann
führt das schlicht und ergreifend zu
einer vertiefung dieses unrechts das
stattgefunden hat das müssen die presse
das muss müssen die medien sich vorfeld
sehr genau überlegen und aus meiner
sicht ist da keine
ruhmreiche entscheidung getroffen worden
noch ist ja überhaupt nicht klar wer
dieses video hergestellt hat und wer ist
verbreitet hat die politische
kommunikation die gesellschaftliche
kommunikation entwickelt es ja nicht zum
guten um es mal so zu formulieren
erwarten sie für die zukunft dass so
etwas wie das was wir jetzt in
österreich erleben schule machen könnte
das ist genau der punkt vor dem ich
warne wenn wir innerhalb in einer
digitalen welt leben und inzwischen
jeder bürger und jede bürgerin
smartphone in der hosentasche hat und
jederzeit zum beispiel einen politiker
beim mittagessen filmen oder aufzeichnen
kann
dann wird es schwere schäden für unser
politisches system geben wenn sich
politiker nicht auch vertraulich und
privat unterhalten können wenn sie
ständig damit rechnen müssen dass
eigentlich privat gedachte konversation
veröffentlicht wird und sie damit
vorgeführt werden das wird unser
gesamtes politisches system beschädigen
und dagegen schützt auch der datenschutz
als konsequenz daraus erbringt würden
sie sagen dass sie sich mehr offene
politische politische kommunikation mit
offenem visier
auch mit dem politischen gegner wünschen
er selbstverständlich jedenfalls müssen
wir uns davor hüten auf illegale mittel
zugreifen also politiker zu verwandten
oder auch ein regierungsmitarbeiter zu
verwanzen heimlich aufzunehmen und mit
diesem material zu arbeiten die presse
hat eine sehr hohe verantwortung in dem
kontext nicht alles was von öffentlichem
interesse ist zu veröffentlichen sondern
sehr genau zusammen vorzugehen schritt
für schritt selbstverständlich darf man
auch das video nutzen aber eben erst in
einem zweiten oder dritten schritt wenn
zum beispiel bestritten wird dass diese
aufzeichnung war sind dass die
berichterstattung korrekt ist dann kann
man auf solche videos zurückgreifen aber
nicht im ersten schritt sagt stefan
brink der datenschutz-beauftragte von
baden württemberg er bringt vielen dank
dafür einen schönen tag noch nach
stuttgart
hier wünsche ich ihnen auch vielen dank